hey friends how's it
going uh Taylor made the comment earlier
that she was concerned that not everyone
here was a real developer because you
were up so
early you surprised me but pleasantly
surprised so I'll take it uh so I am
Scott Hanselman and uh this is Taylor
poxer Taylor is an engineering manager
at Spotify and just generally kick and
butt at all things that she tries and
this is SC Hanselman so he was recently
promoted to the VP of developer
community at Microsoft so let's give it
up for
[Applause]
[Laughter]
him and also he's one of my good friends
and so one thing I appreciate about
Scott is despite the fact that he's been
in the tech industry as long as I've
been alive he's still been able to
maintain that Spirit about him and keep
helping people and pushing things
forward and so I'm looking forward to
doing this today with them I appreciate
that uh elapse time 3 minutes before you
called me
old so that made me feel that made me
feel really good and very welcome so
thank you for that gift anytime uh we
all want you to feel welcome uh as just
as you have welcomed me in my old age uh
and that's really a theme of our talk
and certainly a theme of strange Loop
which is why I think that we all fit
together so nicely is is feeling that
you are in a welcoming space
absolutely so what we're going to try to
talk oh Applause for welcoming hey
this this is a good tip actually for
anyone who's doing a keynote is if you
just need to have evocative stock
photography oh yeah with meaningful
words and then you make awkward pauses
and then someone is going to
empathy right they're natural you're all
Naturals just remember that for later
when it gets really awkward I definitely
will it's going to be great all right
cool so uh we just noticed also that we
can't see our next slide from from that
angle so we're going to go and just take
a look at what our next slide is thanks
for your patience friends all right so
um we want to talk about what meaning
means in creating a career uh and
finding that meaning for yourself uh for
some of us it's money for some of us
it's a sense of community uh like
communities like this uh for some of us
that Community is virtual and for some
of us it is uh
physical uh I'm also been reflecting on
this this promotion that I got which is
this awkward relationship that I have
with both capitalism which made the
promotion possible and also uh the
compliment that it is when you're boss
gives you a promotion it's it's a
compliment and uh you know how you're
supposed to take a compliment and just
shut up and say thank you uh but I'm
from Portland which is basically being
Canadian so I'm like oh sorry sorry oh
ah you so anytime anyone gives me a
compliment like a promotion or whatever
oh uh so when I um got this promo I
didn't know how to deal with it so I
went on a thank you tour and I spent 2
days calling everyone that uh helped me
starting with my fifth grade English
teacher uh my seventh grade math teacher
my eighth grade history teacher uh and
then the professor at Portland Community
College that got me into software
engineering and I went all the way up
through and tell all of my bosses and at
every stop on this tour and some of them
I had to really dig up in like
retirement homes and beaches and Miami
how long has it been since you were in
fifth
grade that's so
mean we're friends I promise I really
care for him I was in fifth grade in
1984 wow where were you in 1984 Taylor
not even thought of
yeah uh and uh in doing that they were
like wow what a wonderful professional
career you've had and like they were
congratulating me and we were going back
and forth complimenting each other and I
I still feel like I'm not a professional
so I've decided that I think there are
no professionals because in talking to
my computer science teacher from uh from
Portland Community College which is a
two-year School in Portland I realized
that every single programming language
every technique every operating system
that I learned in school no longer
exists except for
C there's something that is something
right so that means we should all be
programming in c good night everybody um
so if if there's really no professionals
like maybe I'm just an amateur and I'm
just kind of making it up as I go along
and if we're all amateurs then what are
we really experts at and this has caused
a lot of um uh
onwe malaise I'm using all my fancy
French words to describe uh what that
feels like it's a very much a sense of
um of history and where what what the
hell have I been doing for the last 32
years but then I realized that it's okay
because everyone is an expert at
something
and the one thing that I am an expert in
is my own journey and how I got here and
the plan and the non plans that caused
it all to happen and in doing all of
that I've been finding uh meaning in for
me uh helping people lifting people up
creating generational wealth in an
awkward system and uh enjoying Community
absolutely and in doing that I'm finding
myself spending less time on social
media which I have discovered is
algorithmically designed to make me feel
bad about
myself and the algorithms are different
like we talked about this because you
were like well they don't all make me
feel bad yeah it's like well Tik Tok
teaches me new dances um Instagram says
I should have a private jet and I don't
have one uh Facebook tells me that my
high school friends are doing better
than me like each algorithm is tuned to
make you feel bad about yourself in a
different
way uh do you remember when uh when
little bowwow uh was on an airplane here
this is actually a little screenshot
here this is a a little bowwow on
Instagram getting on his private
jet and then a couple hours later this
is a little bowwow in coach on
Delta and it it turned out that that was
actually uh the Google image for search
for private jet it was the first thing
that came
[Laughter]
up now this is no disrespect to bowow
but it was just like a reminder that
like that's okay if B doesn't have a
private jet I don't need one I'm so I am
totally fine in the the middle seat and
Coach that I took to get here I assume
you were you were comfortable as well
I'm an aisle seat gal you got an aisle
seat yeah the tall guy near the window
tried to get me to switch but I said no
so don't don't let little bow well get
you down and give yourself a little bit
of Grace absolutely and so when you're
making sure that you're not comparing
yourselves to others I also want to make
sure that you're giving yourself Grace
in this screenshot right here there's
two people that I deem incredibly
successful ful and both of them have
taken eles one of them is Suzanne Young
she's a New York Times bestseller she
was planning to have a career high have
people come talk about her book no one
showed up and then Scott empathized with
her and let her know that there was a
time where he was expecting to have a
career high 1,200 people show up only
for two people to show up and I think
one of them was a priest right uh it was
in it was in comex which is a conference
that uh came and went before you were
born
and uh and I was supposed to give a talk
in front of a thousand people and no one
it didn't fill up and it didn't fill up
and I didn't understand where everybody
was and I heard some laughter across the
hallway which is never a good sign uh
and it turns out there was a young
Finnish gentleman who was coming out
with a new operating system at the time
his name was lonus oh not a big deal so
they were at his talk okay uh my talk
had two people show up uh one developer
uh with I think the Nebraska Department
of Forestry and then a priest so I sat
on the edge of the stairs
and I taught this priest how to make
websites so I did I did help the church
but you had
impact impact nonetheless and in that
moment how did you feel I felt like that
was the lowest and worst thing that
could have ever happened to a human uh
and uh but it didn't matter at all yeah
with a little bit of perspective and I
don't know how many years it's been
since it happened you're totally fine
you're the freaking VP life is good and
so that's the thing if people who I
consider to be extremely successful and
I'm sure many of you do too can take
some L's it's okay if you do too it's
all part of the process success is not
linear and we're all just figuring it
out along the way even for myself this
is a video of me in the pandemic towards
the end resigning and going into an
empty office and pouring myself one last
drink of scotch
but it was also a time when I had to
give myself a little bit of Grace
because I had worked over a year in the
pandemic from my tiny condo at a startup
and we all know that startups are chaos
to begin with layer on the chaos of a
panini and it was just a lot but I made
it through and as life got a little bit
more normal I realized that I hated this
job it had gone through a lot of change
and I wanted to switch things up but
anytime that I went to try to job hunt I
just could not find the spoons to do it
and then I found myself talking to
myself in a way that I would never talk
to anybody and let alone somebody that I
care about and so it ended up getting to
a point where I actually had to give
myself some Grace and I ended up taking
a sabatical ended up being able to get
some genuine rest so that I can then
launch into my job hunt and find the
exact job that I needed and so even
though taking rest can seem like a waste
sometime it can be exactly what you need
to take yourself to the next level so
give yourself some Grace take some rest
and it's completely okay and that Grace
can also help you find what is
Meaningful to you in your career at at
this time I was a senior software
engineer but now I'm an engineering
manager through some reflection I
realized that I no longer wanted to be
an IC and I wanted to take on the chaos
that was
management and since careers are
long we're going to have to take some
calculated risks but sometimes we're bad
at math and that's okay Scott has taken
some L's I've taken some L's it's okay
it's all part of the
process uh you're making me think about
an L if I may yeah please throw out the
L's uh I was throw out some L's all I
throw out as El's Taylor
um I want to tell you a story about
man's planing at
scale uh
so uh I live in Portland and I drive up
to Seattle to work at Microsoft every I
know I mean six to8 weeks and I was
doing some web API work on uh and I was
getting deep in the bowels of HTTP uh
and I was in building 42 in the uh in
the uh Kitchen where you get all the
free soda uh so I was I was there
mainlining uh Diet Coke and uh talking
about you know htdp verbs and what was
wrong with them and why they sucked and
a lovely gentleman walked in who looked
kind of like a a a Danish Anderson
Cooper just uh you know had all his hair
and it was Snow Snow White and he was
charming and he got his coffee and he
kind of like joined the circle of us
complaining about HTTP and we vibed a
little bit and had a little back and
forth and then he he walked away uh and
I was ranting and then uh my buddy says
do you know who that was now just for
you as as an aside that never goes well
whatever
comes whatever comes after do you know
who that was it's going to be Taylor
Swift it's going to be Beyond it's going
to be somebody so you just take the L
immediately but I did not not I
persisted uh who who was it who do I
care well no well that was Heinrich
Frisk neelon who's Hinrich Frisk neelson
oh why don't you Google him with
Bing so it turns out turns out that
Heinrich Frisk neelen wrote the
specification for
HTTP and he just happened to work in
building
42 he was Tim burners Le's intern
so you think that you're taking an L I
explained HTTP to the guy that wrote the
specification good night everybody pleas
got and you know this is the thing
though like we're not experts no one's
an expert uh we're all amateurs uh I
love that you were a senior engineer and
now you're a manager do you do you put
Senior on everything do you insist that
people call you senior every time no
right no I'm kidding I'm kidding and and
that's cool because you you like like
the title is the title right like I
didn't my kids have to call me VP now
but nobody else right it's a balance
right so this is uh Hinrich nielson's
boss Tim burners Lee he's actually sir
Tim burners Lee because he's got like a
he's a knight or whatever like um like
Captain Bard and uh he was doing a video
here on web development I want to point
out point out his title
here he he could have said
senior but the real Flex the real Flex
the missing Flex here was that Tim
burners Lee could have just put
the you imagine getting a a business oh
what the well you're
hired ah yes good times this clicker is
killing me I think the thing that that
Taylor and I share is a focus on being
deliberate and intentional we all have
stories like that they're fun they're
they're painful they make you wise uh
they wake you up at 4: or 5 in the
morning the night before a talk at
strange Loop and you just go oh why did
I say that to the guy that invented
HTTP uh but in doing that how we react
and bring meaning to those experiences
is important and we need to do it in an
intentional and a deliberate way you
said take the L that's that's a funny
phrase but you're actually saying sit in
it yeah and steep in the tea that you
have made sometimes you got
to which I think is super important um
and also in this in this this this thank
you tour that I went and did uh I wanted
to think about what it meant to dissect
luck because I tell people that luck is
the my entire career is luck how much
luck was involved in your career a
little bit a little bit mostly just
intense skill yeah exactly right so the
formula though for luck is a known
formula it is opportunity plus being
prepared and this is really significant
because we may have prepared differently
we may have had different opportunities
the result though is that we're here we
have these jobs and we have these
opportunities and I realized that there
are so many people out there that are
deeply prepared that have had no
opportunities yeah and then there's a
bunch of people who got opportunities
just falling at them but they're not
doing the work so I think we both both
agree that it is this
balance that creates luck absolutely and
like you really can't get the luck like
Scott is saying without the work I feel
like again with social media at times it
can feel like oh it's just super easy
Scott and Taylor just breezing through
life but we're doing the work also
behind the scenes even if Scott's not
throwing his L's up on Twitter it's
happening I'm taking L's we're figuring
it out and we're continuing to put in
that work right and like I realize that
we live in a Time on Beyonce's internet
where uh Twitter is a dumpster fire
where you can just go and ask open-ended
questions about JavaScript and get
20,000 followers in a week and that's
like that's now
devell
right that's maybe opportunity but it's
not being prepared and that's not doing
the work and uh hanging out in the lobby
of the Hilton is the opposite of getting
the work done so we have to find that
balance between the having a sabatical
feeding our spirit and spending times
with our community
and disappearing for 3 months and
grinding and doing the thing and then
coming back and then maybe doing a talk
about it absolutely yeah
so intentionality can breed good things
absolutely and so while you're focusing
on being intentional I'm here to tell
you now that if money is Meaningful to
you it's okay to be intentional about it
I know in my career because I do care
about the money that I make and how much
of it I make people have made me feel
bad about it but I like to remind people
that we live in a capitalistic Society
so money can get me a lot of things
living the life that I want to lead
taking care of my family making sure
that they're medically taken care of so
if you want to prioritize it that is
more than okay and another thing for me
with money is that the ego boost as a
black woman I know that we have
historically been underpaid so I love
making sure that I'm doing my due
diligence to make sure that I am not
part of that statistic and getting that
ego bump every time it happens and I'm
not saying you have to be intentional in
the way that I did in my last job hunt
which was directly tweeting out exactly
the base salary that I want and the
other requirements that I want in said
job but by letting your company know
that you are caring about money it can
actually get it to you faster especially
if you're going out of your way to do
the work that you need to to make it
happen and for those who do not know I
made this big salary on the back of PHP
and
[Laughter]
larable
and honestly it's a hill that I would
die on like when I was a senior software
engineer it was for PHP and Lal if you
do need a backend service I highly
recommend checking it
out um and here's Scott right here
mentioning that money can be the motive
this person the Scott is replying to it
saying that you need the passion to be
in the dev Community but I'm here to
tell you now and I think Scott would
agree if his tweet is true that you can
just do it for the money it's okay and
like one of the benefits of being an old
man on the Internet is you can find
takes like this and just reply with like
nah it's okay and and that's that's cool
like look at that like if I could eat
you know Chipotle based on likes I did
okay on that one uh but like this is a
stupid take yeah here's the deal like
two things can be true at the same time
they can money is good and passion is
good and having a balance of both is
probably best but don't go and say only
only people should Co you you should
only be a plumber if you're passionate
about the
Pips that's stupid it's stupid and the
thing is is that like this person is
saying you won't be Innovative but most
of us like okay I work for Spotify my
team is doing advertisement stuff we may
not be like the people that are driving
Innovation but we're pretty dang good at
our jobs and money can motivate has to
be good at our jobs because if taking
care of the people that we love most is
the thing that is more than okay I may
not be the number one engineer in the
world creating all the new tech that you
all will then use but I'm okay with that
I don't know about you Scott I am deeply
okay with that and in fact uh a lot of
people don't realize that I went to
Microsoft originally for the healthcare
yeah uh CU I'm Type 1 diabetic and I've
got you know an insulin pump and a bunch
of equipment me a couple of grand every
month to stay alive and Microsoft had
really good Healthcare yeah so if you
ask me uh like on the street why I went
to work there it would be like well that
you know to help the billions of people
achieve their best selves
uh but it really the answer was yeah
right so yeah it's all that free insulin
and but also when I went to Microsoft uh
people were calling me a sellout cuz I
was a uh I was an open source person I
spent 15 years doing open source and
then I joined Microsoft and it hurt they
were like you're a sellout oh Microsoft
with a dollar sign you suck Hanselman
and like that's that made me feel bad
and it took a while to like to get over
that you know what I mean but I I I went
internally and I dug deep and I found it
in myself to feel good about my
experience working at some gr there
making it
through uh but actually one of the
things that I'm super passionate about
is is Healthcare and speaking of
diabetes here's a picture of baby
handan a ow what they're doing is
they're mourning the hair that was
actually not an awe that was like
a that is a picture of me in The
Oregonian in the late '90s because I
wrote an application uh to manage my
blood sugar on the Palm
Pilot and uh yeah let's see all right
this is really useful right I heard
money they applaud for money empathy and
Palm Pilot just keep going them out keep
going them out we need to get Harry Mack
in here to do an improvised rap on those
three words this is going to be great I
also want to call out the fresa bottles
on top of the Stony
Trinitron right there that is I don't
know why they're like we're going to
come take a picture of you don't clean
up they want to really capture the
essence of how you the essence of
[Laughter]
diabetes I love that you wrote a
diabetes app do you think the Fresca was
involved
in not not no that's actually sugar-free
but still um but creating an application
that helped people manage their blood
sugar got me excited and got me involved
and since then I've been doing advocacy
work with open source artificial
pancreases which I'm currently actually
running an open source artificial
pancreas right now hell yeah so that's
super
important
quick so so let's just mourn baby
hansome one for a
second oh
just needed an animated gift of me
getting old Taylor sorry you go ahead
over here drinking soda
pop ah sorry please
continue and so like also as we're in
our careers making sure that we're doing
something meaningful can be highly
personal what I like doing and what
Scott likes doing is going to be
completely different but that's totally
part of the process as well so if you're
comparing yourselves to others in that
way also make sure that you're not doing
that and genuinely listening to yourself
to make sure that whatever you are feel
feeling is okay when I first started
this career as I mentioned I ended up
wanting to work towards being a senior
software engineer that happened ended up
having my startup acquired layoffs Mass
attrition a bunch of chaos with
leadership and I was burnt out but what
they ended up doing because I was one of
three back-end Engineers that had the
knowledge that they had bought the
company for they gave me a team again
not against my will but I was not
thrilled so to my surprise I ended up
loving it when I started my career I had
a manager that was awful and so being
able to carve out a little safe Corner
in the company where a team was
productive and happy fulfilled me in a
way that I never could have imagined and
so I abandoned that IC path and then
went to my clicker is not working either
W went to uh being an engineering
manager which is what I am now so shift
happens that is okay listen to yourself
and make sure you're constantly
recalibrating exactly what direction
Direction you want to go to make it
happen when in your career did you start
to drink to excess cuz cuz I know on
Instagram you're woman with whiskey and
I know that if there's two things that
we do uh a lot of is whiskey and diet
soda pop oh yeah um I think is
that is that a coping mechanism cuz it's
okay that like I'm a diet soda Simo oh
yeah right yeah I'm a whiskey K OFA yeah
cuz I'm drinking diet Pepsi cuz it's the
only thing they had here that's actually
whiskey in that B I'm not this is
whiskey
I'm not very happy about
this I was actually surprised to see you
pick it up I saw diet it's the only
option that I had and it was weird
because it got the Retro bottle but
there's a whole thing here but I knew
immediately it was a good week
okay but you were a senior engineer and
I think of uh that I think when I think
of you I think of like you know hacker
well not hacker man hacker Taylor yeah
exactly that's me every day at my
startup but that wasn't the meaning that
you wanted being a senior engineer
wasn't where you found meaning yeah
eventually at the time I thought that is
what I found meaning in but what I
really was doing was trying to prove
that first manager wrong so I was like
hell bent on getting the senior software
engineer because he told me I would
never make it in Tech and then once I
got there I was like oh okay perfect but
then once I really like listened to
myself I realized it wasn't what poured
into me um as I uh am kind of getting
towards the waning years of my career
and thinking about when I'm going to
retire I think about how stuff that I
say might land and I worry sometimes if
I tell someone you know you need to show
a little resilience you need a little
you use the word grit yesterday you need
to show grit it might land wrong yeah
because sometimes if I go let's say I go
on Twitter I'm like yall need to stop
screwing around you need to do your job
you know I'm going to switch jobs every
three months you need to stay at your
job for two years because that's how
organizational change happens that could
land wrong on Twitter but I could say
the exact same thing to uh someone on my
team yeah and it might land perfectly
correct so so when is grit and Technical
resilience and you know old man shakes
fistic cloud or Taylor shakes fistic
Cloud appropriate young and when is it
not appropriate for me it's when the
trust has been established So currently
right now I have a manager that I don't
want to say stays on me but she gives me
constant feedback and I love it but when
I joined Spotify I told her I wanted to
be a director of engineering in five
years and she said that was a very
aggressive goal but she was going to
help me get there so she stays on me she
gives me a ton of feedback but I always
take it with Grace because I know that
her impact is to always lift me up and
never tear me down and trying to get me
exactly where I want to go so it's the
established trust that I think makes it
a bit different so the exact same
message regardless of identity gender
age all the different factors in the pie
chart of who we are could be delivered
to an internet stranger and that's being
abusive and to a cooworker that you
trust who you know wants you to win can
be exactly what they need to take it to
the next level absolutely right and in
that case it can potentially give them
meaning in their in their careers uh
before I was a VP at Microsoft we had
this title called partner like partner
in a law firm and my boss would tell me
to do stuff and I would always wonder
like do I really have to do that thing
uh one time uh I had to go and do some
paper and I didn't want to do the paper
and he says partner up and he was
basically saying this is the job this is
the rank this is the title this is the
paycheck do your job yeah and I was like
that makes me feel some kind of way
and he's like you still need to do your
job that was tough love Yeah but we
still went to dinner that night and we
talked about life and our kids yeah I
know he wants me to win when we were
coming out on stage about a half an hour
ago you said they want us to win yeah so
when we feel nervous we realize that
we're not ice skating uphill this is a
this is an audience that wants us to win
and if you're engineering manager at
Spotify wants you to win then that
technical resilience that they're
insisting that you have is is
appropriate but if a random person on
the internet that doesn't know you or
love you tells you to suck it up and get
some grit that's going to hurt yeah
they're going to geted out that's good
advice thank you for
that and so also because our careers on
average are going to be around 40 years
some of you may strike a big with a good
startup exit and retire early but on
average our careers are going to be
around 40 years we have to embrace the
unknowns there's no way that we could
exact map out what is going to happen in
that career and chart along just fine
unless I guess you stay at one company
for like 40 years and even that has some
like unknown bits about it so one of my
favorite quotes is from Antoine Day St
exupery he is actually the author of The
Little Prince and it goes as for the
future your task is not to foresee it
but to enable it and I think it's so
perfect because not only is he admitting
that you don't have to have it all
figured out that you just have to have
like a pth path forward that you're
charting on but also it reminds me of
The Little Prince because basically The
Little Prince travels around different
universes and figures out life lessons
and that's more or less how I figure out
or I consider my career to be learning
lessons and then making adjustments
along the way so I can still make sure
that I have the most fulfilling path
possible but the hard part is that
because we have to embrace the unknown
it can be a bit uncomfortable there are
going to be times where you're in the
mix of it and you don't know if you're
drowned
and what I mean by Drowning is like
you're going to go through this a bunch
of bad stuff and almost nothing positive
is going to come out of it you just feel
overwhelmed and a bit you know hopeless
in a way and I think Scott you made a
good point last night about stretch
goals like when you're in it and you are
technically drowning but you can kind of
push off right so when you're drowning
are you really drowning or can you
bounce and touch the bottom of the pool
yeah if you can if you're 5T tall but
you're in 6 fet of water water that's
where growth happens but if you're 5T
tall and you were just yeed into the
deep end of the pool then you can't even
can think of the of the of the B base of
the pool then you're in trouble growth
happens when you're stretching not when
you when you're drowning exactly and my
equivalent of that is going to be when
you're in over your head but you're
still amongst your flowers and what I
mean by that is so like a couple of
months at work I was stressed I was
really reaching the end of my wits and I
couldn't decide at the time if I was
drowning or if I was in over my head but
amongst my flowers and towards the end I
started to realize that yes I was
overwhelmed but I was actually just
amongst my flowers and the reason why I
say that is because I was surrounded by
a team of people that were eager to make
sure that I succeeded and so even though
I was experiencing things as a manager
that I had never had happen my manager
and my upper management was right there
with me coaching me through and making
sure that I didn't fail and so when
you're sitting with the unknown there
will be some time where you can't decide
which is which but just sit with it and
if you decide that you're drowning take
a step away but if you're aure of
flowers Embrace that growth opportunity
and push
through and this next one is going to be
one of my favorite quotes we're going to
ignore the fact that Theodore Roosevelt
is only talking to men but I think it's
I think it's absolutely amazing I Chang
it the person in the title
here and so it goes it is not the critic
who counts not the man who points out
how the strong man stumbles or where the
doer of Deeds could have done them
better the credit belongs to the man who
is actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust and sweat and blood who
strives valiantly who airs who comes up
short again and again because there is
no effort without error anytime I am
doubting myself or I feel like I can't
push through and I know there are
sometimes reasons why people can't push
through any number of reasons I'm not
talking about that I remind myself that
I get credit for being in the fight I'm
not going to have everything figured out
out but I'm working at it and I'm going
to make my way through especially with
the support of my community and so I
want to remind folks of that again give
yourself some Grace because by embracing
these unknowns you never know where it
is going to take you like even here this
is me attending my first strange Loop in
2017 I was sitting right over there with
some of my co-workers James sleeping in
this is not a sign of the quality of the
talk he was very tired from travel but
at this time time I was on that path to
be a senior software engineer had just
started at this startup and if I'm being
100% honest I wasn't even excited to
come to strange Loop it was the only
conference I could afford and so my team
ended up convincing me ended up coming
here and lo and behold strange Loop
became my number one conference to the
point where even this year I was
catching up with some of my friends and
I was like oh I'm key noting my favorite
conference and everybody literally every
single one of them was like strange Loop
and so I was like yeah and I was like
how did you know they're like you
literally have not shut up about that
conference for what feels like a
freaking decade and so there's no way
that 2017 Taylor could have known that
she would not only no longer be on the
IC path she would be an engineering
manager no longer obsessed with working
for small companies but working at a
decent sized company like Spotify but
that also at the time I wasn't even like
caring about talking at conferences that
I would be talking
at the last conference for strange Loop
and keynoting it with Scott Hanselman
who at the time I knew of but I wouldn't
have no offense I would have considered
him a friend but now but now I very much
consider him a friend just because I
feel like we've grown closer and whatnot
so by embracing the unknowns being
willing to go to St Louis even though I
I wasn't sure that I wanted to I was
able to con was able to connect with
people and be enriched by this community
of amazing strange Loop attendees over
the years year years and be able to have
this uh experience which I'm really
grateful for so what I'm hearing though
is that there was a master plan that
your entire career was orchestrated you
planned it all out you took like vision
boards and stuff oh yeah and you yeah
I've seen the vision board absolutely um
how much was it planned because I feel
like people are constantly coming up to
me and saying how do you manage your
personal brand right and mostly my
personal brand is just like posting
animated Gifts of Neil Patrick Harris
uh that's not it's got me this far uh
how much it is it being a plan and how
much of it is being intentional about
being open to the possibilities for me I
like to do a lot of uh medium-term goals
and then as I'm like charting my way
through those medium-term goals like
checking in with myself to see what I'm
feeling like okay like when I first
joined Spotify I said I wanted to be
director of engineering I've been at
Spotify now for two years and that role
is looking questionable to me so like I
no longer know if I would want to put up
with the things that a director of
engineering would want to I'm still
continuing on that path medium-term goal
and just figuring out which ways i' want
to go as I get closer to it do you ever
have that thing where you bump into
people from back in the day and they're
like ah I knew you were going to do
great things and I knew you whatever and
and you're like I
didn't yeah I feel like it's easy to say
now like of course you did you say that
now yeah with hindsight were're able to
go and look at these things when I did
my thank you tour I was going around and
they were all like oh we knew you do
great things and like I'm sure you
planned it all out I'm like I have no
idea but I was looking for meaning and
that meaning was kindness people I
enjoyed going to work with like uh
having a decent boss like it's almost
more important that you have a good boss
then you enjoy what you're working on
absolutely a horrible boss will betray
you yeah 100% And also like eat away at
your like energy and your ego like I
think one of the game changers for the
last two years and the reason I've been
able to grow the way that I have it's CU
I have such a supportive manager that
just pours into me non-stop but where do
you see the difference between goals and
plans I think sometimes people use those
things interchangeably I feel like plans
are more detailed like it's like down to
the bones like I'm going to do this I'm
going to do this I'm going to do this
right now I'm like okay director of
engineering I don't want to say pie in
the sky it's a very reasonable goal for
me to have maybe not fiveyear goal but
um or Now threee goal but you know
there's a goal and kind of like Loosely
working through it right and goals can
change and goals can be be happy be
content uh be able to put my bills on
autopay yeah that's a great goal it is a
great goal being able to do that uh
double meat at Chipotle was a goal for
me all the now I I just constantly
carneada dose uh triple guac absolutely
uh and then being able to expense it oh
even Flex on Flex just going to say um
but then making a plan we said plans
third trying to just deemphasize like
have a plan but understand that life is
just a series of scrums you're going to
do these iterations if you're heading in
the general direction of your goal
you're going to be okay but if you make
a perfect plan and then you miss you're
going to be sad I missed the target but
you are kind of heading in that gener
that direction yeah and also like life
is full of so many unknowns so like
nothing's ever going to go 100% exactly
the way you plan it so you might as well
not even fully try like this talk
yeah
we we practice we practice this a bunch
of different times we're like how do we
where are we going to stand how far are
you going to step I'll step back and
then we we were literally in the in the
hotel last night trying to figure out we
almost got to the masking tape part on
the ground we're like I think that would
be weird to have marks to stand on but
but then we're like no we know what we
want to say we know how we want people
to feel the point is if you find meaning
that meaning might be I want to work on
this language I want to work with these
people I want to work at this company it
might be I want to move the ball forward
for healthare or for music or for social
justice or for whatever oh yeah and as
long as you're moving towards that
you're going to find some meaning so we
have a little homework for you yeah
here's your picture this is the one
where you take a picture so we'll do
we'll just pose and you take a picture
and here's your
homework that's our anime so first thing
on how to build a meaningful career is
avoid comparison comparison is the thief
of Joy we've talked about that try to
live as intentionally as possible Taylor
talked about Grace Grace
is something you have to give yourself
intentionally you have to just stop for
a second and you go yeah that sucked but
it's going to be okay I like that timer
thing you your mom said oh yeah my mom
talk about Scott's mom so I I I screwed
up at work uh I was on this call a
freaking virtual I've been virtual at
Microsoft the entire time so I'm on this
call and I thought it was like a call of
like eight people and they were like hey
what why did this thing happen I was
like ah it was a failure of marketing
and then I looked at at the call it
wasn't an 8 it was
81 there were 81 people on the call
including
marketing and then you know the little
popups that that happen on Windows is
called toast where it's just like boom
boom and they're like so and so is
chatting you so and so is teaming you or
whatever so I said oh yeah it was a
failure of marketing I was
like so my boss was like that was a
miss so then I immediately felt like oh
this is it this is how the badge gets
deactivated
I
right and then I was like well no uh cuz
you have to go through all the stages of
guilt no I'm speaking truth to power
man you guys suck no but it turns out
that it's you can speak truth to power
quietly in in one-on-one meetings and
not in group not in recorded group
meetings so I immediately took the L
apologized called the people who weren't
on the call and warned them that the
call was coming uh and and I also
explained why I felt that way and we we
fixed it yeah but man 25-year-old Scott
would have taken that totally
differently but now educated experienc
Scott was like yep that was a learning
opportunity I felt it in the moment it
also sounded like you VPD up I VPD up
there you go okay and I did some hard
work and doing hard work helps you uh
helps you grow yeah that's a lot of
uncomfortable conversations too but you
did it I'm very proud of you did so a
little additional homework for you
Taylor right on the right there yeah
giving yourself Grace and I Scott just
touched on that long careers there's no
way we can get it all perfectly right
you're human it's all part of the
process and your motivation is yours and
yours alone whatever motivates you it's
more than okay focus on that maximize
that and you're going to have a pretty
solid career and then embracing the
unknown again there's no way we can know
it all but we're doing our best along
the way and that's all we could ask for
yeah we hope that you found a little
tiny bit of meaning in our talk and
hopefully you're finding meaning in your
careers I know that you will find
meaning though in some of the great
talks at strange Loop over the next
couple days and uh we thank you so much
for choosing to spend time with us today
yeah absolutely thank
you